the Baseball Hall of Fame had its
induction ceremonies in Cooperstown this
past weekend last time this gentleman
was on the show I was saying you know
what a lot of people said when you talk
about best players or pitchers of a
generation this guy was exactly that you
knew it was a big game if he was on the
mound you knew if it was a big game to
win he was more likely to win it on the
mound and whatever was holding him back
from going into Cooperstown is now a
moot point he is a baseball
hall-of-famer
he is Jack Morris here on the show how
are you jack almost a week Cooperstown
New York so what was it like was it what
you had always thought it could be you
know it's hard to imagine that you
vision something and it actually turns
out better than that but you know the
lesson I learned from it is time was on
my side and the love that I experienced
from so many people was something I wish
I could give everyone so what did you
what did you what's your favorite memory
from the weekend what are you gonna
remember you know I think I think my
favorite memory is just I was just
blessed to go in with a clash group of
guys the other five inductees got home a
little bit better on a personal level
and I think they're just tired of people
and they brought quality messages to so
many fans their gratitude through all of
our accomplishments what would it mean
for you to go in with Trammell fellow
Tigers Jack that's like going in with
your best friend your little brother you
know it's somebody that helped me get
there
enjoyed the process along the way from
when we were young young kids out of
high school in college growing into you
know grown men in the baseball diamond
and now in the latter stages of our life
and still able to collect other friends
and share great memories so well which
now fellow member of the Baseball Hall
of Fame did you meet four
first time and kind of perhaps got a
little bit awestruck starstruck
overwhelmed to say that we're now
hall-of-famers together you know I don't
mean this disrespectfully but I've
pretty much known most of the guys and
wasn't anybody that I hadn't met before
okay and there was there were several
people that weren't there for various
reasons then I would love to have been
there to say hi to Bob Gibson comes to
mind Sandy Koufax you know those kind of
guys weren't there but with that being
said I think it just was an overwhelming
feeling to have so many of the Hall of
Famers that I know in my heart were
pulling for me for a long time just
somewhat relieved that I'm now part of
their group Jack Morris Hall of Famer
here on the Rich Eisen show and just to
look back in the rearview mirror one
more time why do you think it took so
long jack well I think I was a guy that
way of thinking versus analytics
generation determined into the world
after my career numbers and formulas and
all sorts of analytics you know some of
those numbers weren't favorable for me
and that's probably why the discussion
keeps alarms winners well I mean when it
all comes down to it though did you do
you think maybe your relationship with
media members had anything to do with it
no way Jack well that would be on mom
not on me you know because I wasn't
voting for them they were voting for me
so if that were true then than us all
right and I guess one more thing for you
Jack the way that the game is being
played today with all the other
relievers coming in do you see anybody
who has got a mentality in Major League
Baseball today that is similar to yours
or one that you respect
oh there's a lot of guys it's just a lot
of you know all the great pictures of
today's generation have the same
mentality you know kluever you go on and
on and on the difference is they're not
allowed to do what we were allowed to do
and I really think in time baseball will
probably come full circle and it'll go
back to the way the game was played for
a hundred plus years and that is the
starting pitcher goes out there and
dominates as long as possible and then
the relievers come in for the help
needed not necessarily a strategy of mix
and match righty lefty you know try to
get the numbers say this guy gets tired
after this many innings you know it's
it's it's the strong the game in my
opinion for our games are nothing that
anybody wants to watch nobody goes old
ballgame to see 14 pitchers pitching a
game they usually you know for
generations they went out to see two
guys battle against each other so nobody
ever came to you and said you know
Jackie are the numbers show that the
third time around in the order you were
a little bit weaker so you're coming out
of the game that never happened to you
Jack Morris what would have happened if
that had happened in your life Jack I
would have got better at the third time
around great answer great answer you got
how could you have done that Jack Morris
you know I've done that well you you
know I think for most athletes in every
sport when you tell them they can't
that's what motivates and you know I
just think that's what's built inside of
the great athletes it's a match that
everybody well Jack like I said prior to
you coming on and the last time when you
were on I just knew that whenever you
were on the mound it was gonna be a long
night for whoever or short night for
whoever you were pitching against and
then just some of these great games that
you have pitched in in the history and
then refused to come out of the game and
give the ball up you deserve the
enshrinement so thanks for coming on you
got that's Jack Morris baseball
hall-of-famer the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience